after a long long long wait it's finally
here our first teaser for thor love and
thunder and it tells us
not a lot that we didn't already know to
be honest don't get me wrong there is a
lot already crammed into here you have
thor getting back in shape a new look
for everyone's favorite rock monster
korg valkyrie atop her throne as king
guest appearances from the guardians of
the galaxy a look at the mcu's version
of zeus atop mount olympus and of course
the first reveal of a reforged mjolnir
wielded by jane foster as mighty thor
but you know what that's all stuff that
either directly carries over from end
game or has been heavily talked about in
the press over the last three years you
know i just i just wanted something more
something a bit more plot related beyond
thor needs yet another movie to find
himself but then i looked a little
closer and i found nothing but then i
listened a little closer and yeah here's
the thing i think this teaser actually
is telling us a lot more than we might
think maybe even setting up stuff
that'll be huge not just for the thor
franchise but for the entire marvel
cinematic universe which you know would
be one of the reasons they've kept this
one hidden for so long call me crazy i
think the clue that unlocks it all is
this
hold on is this
it's the song okay i can't play it for
you without getting claimed hi heaven
can we just play like three seconds
[Music]
good as i'm gonna get sweet child of
mine by guns and roses this song right
here holds the big reveal to this entire
movie in the very first teaser a reveal
that has nothing to do with anything
that we've shown or talked about yet and
i'm about to decode it for you today
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that's asking you to start
knock knock knocking on that subscribe
button that's a that's another guns and
roses reference in case you didn't know
trust me if you value being the person
that knows everything before the rest of
the world does today is the day that i
earn that subscription because i feel
really good about this one plus
subscribing is free and really helps us
out alright you've seen the trailer
you've seen the reactions you've seen
the breakdowns but you haven't seen this
this entire movie is spoiled in a single
song sweet child of mine by guns and
roses third single off their 1988 album
appetite for destruction and the band's
only number one song in the us believe
it or not but why is it here why is this
song the one chosen for the teaser just
a high-energy 80s song to set the
trailer to right wrong you see thor love
and thunder is being directed by taiko
watidi the same director who did thor
ragnarok and wouldn't you know it but he
basically told us the entire plot of
that movie in its trailer choice of song
as well we just didn't know it at the
time just to refresh your memory thor
ragnarok was all about the norse god
thor being sent to a foreign planet
where he had to fight alongside his
trickster brother loki in order to
escape along the way he has to come to
terms with asgard's bloody history of
conquest the movie ultimately ends with
them blowing up their homeland and
leaving aboard a spaceship looking for a
new place to call home and now let's
revisit the song from the trailer
[Music]
great love music copyrights that is all
i get to play that ah song is called the
immigrant song by led zeppelin a song
whose lyrics talk about all the stuff we
discovered first taking the lyrics at
face value they're literally just
talking about norse mythology with lines
like valhalla i'm coming so immediately
there's a connection between thor and
the song but then you have quotes in the
song like the hammer of the gods will
drive our ships to new lands sounds like
a bunch of displaced asgardians on board
a spaceship looking for their new home
and again in the middle of the song you
have the lyrics how soft your fields can
whisper tales of gore we are your
overlords seems to me like a really
strong parallel to the movie's
exploration of odin's bloody conquests
and how asgard this beautiful realm is
built atop the brutal slaughter of other
lands i mean even the song's name
immigrant song tells us that this is a
story where people are going to be
displaced from their homeland be it thor
landing on sakhar or again the
asgardians looking for a new home at the
end of the movie in short when tyka is
choosing a song for his trailers the
thought process goes just a wee bit
deeper than catchy old song go br which
is why we have to talk about sweet child
of mine for the new love and thunder
teaser now the song itself is pretty
simple it's a song that was written by
the lead singer axel rose for his
girlfriend and the lyrics are all about
a beautiful blonde girl with blue eyes
who serves as a shelter safe haven for
him for instance quote her hair reminds
me of a warm safe place where i'd hide
and pray for the thunder and the rain to
quietly pass me by and considering that
this is a movie featuring the return of
jane foster thor's girlfriend from the
first two movies in the series people
are assuming that she's the sweet child
of mine she's the girlfriend that's
being referenced here the fact that
she's taken up mjolnir only forwards
that she's now a girlfriend acting as a
protector for a boy that's tired of
fighting a boy who wants the thunder to
pass him by his hands were once used for
battle now they're about humble tools
for peace and yeah that is a perfectly
valid interpretation it could just be as
simple as that pretty much what you see
is what you get girlfriend protecting
boyfriend who's tired of fighting very
literal interpretation of the song
except i think that there are a couple
elements of the song that these
interpretations tend to overlook first
off like i mentioned the girl has blonde
hair and blue eyes jane foster in the
movies it has neither of those it's a
superficial detail to be sure but this
is also a series all about a norse
family where everyone tends to have
blonde hair and blue eyes thor blonde
with blue eyes his mother frigga blonde
blue eyes the teaser even emphasizes the
bright blue of thor's eyes with an
extreme close-up the other thing worth
mentioning though is that the girl in
the song isn't just a girlfriend this is
someone who is specifically reminding
the singer of being a child a time when
things were safer and simpler the
opening lines themselves read she's got
a smile that seems to me reminds me of
childhood memories where everything was
as fresh as the bright blue sky it's
also worth noting that all these
memories wind up is bittersweet quote
again if i stare too long i'd probably
break down and cry there's a sadness
about what's been lost here and a
longing to go back to that time later in
the song her hair reminds him of a place
where as a child he'd hide there's a
family component here a childhood
component and while jane foster could
certainly remind thor of his younger
days he wasn't so young that he was a
child when he first met her watch what
image the teaser chooses to open with
thor running through the generations of
his life thor as a kid jane is a human
who met with him well into his young
adult life she doesn't have that sort of
history it's also worth noting that
sweet child mind turns dark around the
midpoint of the song repeating the
phrase where do we go now over and over
and over again something has happened to
prompt a new status quo where do we go
now it's an upheaval of some kind though
that section of the song isn't in the
teaser it feels important to the
narrative that it's trying to sell us so
if the sweet child of mine isn't
referencing jane then who is it the way
i see it there's two possible directions
ladies and gentlemen it's double theory
day or i guess it's triple theory day
since it could just be jane and we just
talked about that anyway theory number
one or two depending on how you're
counting the sweet child of mine is thor
himself he's got blonde hair and blue
eyes after all the song could be from a
parent singing about their child thor
but what parent after dark world and
ragnarok both of thor's parents are dead
right right yeah not necessarily
he's adopted in classical norse
mythology odin got around when it came
to fatherhood and in the thor comics
it's more or less the same so the
subject of exactly who thor's biological
mother is has been a question kicked
around for decades for a while it was
assumed that he was actually the baby of
odin and gaia as in the planet literally
odin hooked up with planet earth rick
sanchez style isn't it obvious morty
more recently though this has actually
changed see as part of a huge avenger
storyline involving the avengers the
eternals loki the celestials and the
dark celestials spoiler alert but that's
a thing it was revealed that way back at
the dawn of the universe earth had
picked up its propensity for being full
of magic users mutants superheroes and
all the other marvel stuff basically
because the corpse of a dead celestial
had fallen here and bled out while the
world was forming when its celestial
friend zagreb the sorrower came looking
for it centuries later in prehistoric
times he was defeated by a team of stone
age superheroes assembled on the spot as
the actual first avengers a lineup
consisting of the first iron fist the
first black panther the first star brand
agamoto as in eye of agamotto the first
sorcerer supreme and a caveman ghost
rider atop a flaming woolly mammoth so
why do i bring this up outside of being
a chance to tell you that the avengers
of 10 000 bc is an actual thing that
exists and we might one day see a
flaming skeleton atop a burning woolly
mammoth well the story was actually
written by jason aaron the same writer
responsible for story lines where jane
foster becomes thor gore the god butcher
decimates everyone and where scenes like
this happen all of which wouldn't you
know are being recreated in this new
movie in short he's a guy whose
influence is being felt all over love
and thunder in fact all over the mcu
right now you know that mountain-sized
petrified celestial that's left sticking
out of the ocean at the end of eternals
yeah that is right out of another of
jason aaron's projects the avengers end
up using it as their new house just
saying this guy's opinion matters right
now and as part of this ancient caveman
avengers you also had odin himself join
the battle alongside a cave woman a
mutant cave woman who it turns out was
the first host of the phoenix yep the
x-men's cosmic phoenix force and it's
worth noting this isn't just a storyline
that was randomly dropped in 2021's also
jason aaron's scripted arc avengers
enter the phoenix the phoenix force
returns as a villain and cut to the
chase and she probably figured it out
thor confronts her and she calls him my
son the phoenix force explicitly says
you are the child of fire and thunder
it's yet another secret that odin has
kept from him for his entire life and
that's kind of where things leave off
right now the comic was left on a
cliffhanger waiting for resolution a
resolution that once you know it is
slated for this july the same month that
love and thunder is scheduled to hit
theaters this whole time we've been
expecting the love part of love and
thunder to relate to jane foster as
thor's ex-girlfriend but what if it's a
different kind of love parental love the
love between odin and thor's real mom
the phoenix should we be putting all our
bets on thor's mom being revealed as the
flaming space bird from the x-men well
honestly maybe i mean the timing the
song the secrecy the fact that more and
more incidental minor x-men stuff keeps
creeping in at the margins all of it
seems to line up it also ties back to
the childhood themes that we were
talking about present in the song lyrics
it would also make sense with the whole
where do we go now section of the song
with an upheaval like that i mean where
do you go thor is set more adrift than
ever so i think that there's a lot of
evidence going for that theory but
thor's mommy issues aren't the only
asgardian family drama to consume this
side of marvel comics for over the past
decade a few years earlier thor and loki
also got themselves a surprise half
sister named angela and if you thought
it was weird that thor is now halfway
related to the x-men angela comes from
another comic book universe at another
comic book publisher she's an angel from
heaven she's one of the bad guys which
brings us to theory number two the sweet
child is angela asgard's assassin
thor and loki's long-lost sister
daughter of odin who if you're into some
of the various marvel games cartoons and
toy runs from the last couple years you
might have run across you will pay the
price for striking my brother as far as
characters go she's a relatively new
addition becoming a marvel character in
2013 but the story of how it happened
actually stretches all the way back to
the 1950s you see back in the 1930s this
superman-like red costumed character now
called shazam used to be called captain
marvel to spare the details in the late
30s superman was just really starting to
take off in popularity which prompted
another company fawcett comics to
introduce captain marvel a character
that basically had all the same powers
as superman except with a twist he was a
boy who transformed by saying the word
shazam and he was popular so popular in
fact that for a while he sold more
comics than superman even becoming the
first superhero ever put to film which
fun fact is available almost in its
entirety on youtube i'll link to it in
the description despite being 80 years
old it's really fun holds up shockingly
well i
am
shazam all is known to me your name is
billy batson but who is captain marvel
you are my son all that is necessary is
to repeat my name
shazam shazam
anyway dc comics thought captain marvel
was just a shameless rip-off of superman
i mean they weren't all together wrong
and they sued fawcett comics out of
existence however as they tried to snap
up all the heroes in fawcett's roster
they forgot to trademark the name
captain marvel which allowed a small
unknown publisher to do it before them
the publisher's name marvel this was why
dc had to change the character's name to
shazam and how marvel comics was born it
also prompted an independent publisher
named l miller in sun limited to make
the character marvel man a british
superhero with the same basic powers to
replace reprints of captain marvel that
were still popular in the uk fast
forwarding the story a bit marvel man
would get rebooted in the 80s re-titled
his miracle man for the united states
and get even more popular but his
stories would ultimately go unfinished
when part of the rights were purchased
by the creator of the spawn comics todd
mcfarlane the tldr of this is that todd
was holding miracle man hostage to use
as a bargaining chip against a fellow
co-creator neil gaiman in yet another
legal battle he was having over
ownership of spawn characters the main
character in contention there a very
popular sexy demon hunting angel named
angela this case was way too drawn out
to go into but it lasted for over 15
years and ended with marvel helping neil
gaiman out mcfarland ultimately loses
which grants gaiman control over miracle
man and angela as a thanks for helping
him out he gifts angela to marvel to use
it as they see fit in their official 616
universe and that is how a spawn
character one of the few well-known
comic series that don't belong to either
dc or marvel ultimately wound up in
marvel's roster
okay as interesting and convoluted as
all that is here's where it actually
becomes relevant to our theory today
when marvel had to explain how a literal
angel from actual heaven was now hanging
around the marvel timeline the gimmick
they came up with was to have her pop
into reality following a multiverse
breaking event and subsequently discover
that she was actually an asgardian
specifically she's aldriff oden's
daughter very subtle there guys odin's
first born who is believed killed but
actually stolen as a baby during a
forgotten war between asgard and a race
called angels from the long lost tenth
realm a familiar looking place full of
pearly gates and self-righteousness
called heaven spelled differently
h-e-v-e-n completely different things
certainly weird but still not as awkward
as that time when ghost rider teamed up
with jesus more than once since then
angela has been all over marvel in her
own series in the thor comics as a
member of the guardians of the galaxy
sorry as a member of the asgardians of
the galaxy usually in search of her one
true love sarah who also happens to be
one of marvel's original transgender
heroes so a lot is going on with this
particular character but could any of it
plausibly make it into this movie well
we know in the comics that she came to
the marvel universe because of tares
getting ripped in the multiverse kind of
like the ones that just happened in loki
and in spider-man no way home and
probably in doctor strange too we also
know that this new movie is visiting
places like mount olympus and characters
like zeus in fact more and more we've
been seeing real world mythologies
getting represented in the mcu obviously
north mythology has been represented
since the beginning but now we have the
grecian gods here the egyptian gods over
in moon knight the mythic creatures of
ancient china and shang chi's tallow
thor was a myth and now i study him in
my physics class in love and thunder
we're supposed to have a main antagonist
called gore the god butcher with a name
like that you're gonna need some gods to
butcher and in a movie where you're
already visiting mount olympus it would
make sense to potentially also visit a
non-secular place called heaven to join
forces with or fight against some sort
of angel army plus based on these shots
here we know thor is going to be
spending time in outer space notice the
moons and sun in the sky this is not
earth we also know that he's spending a
lot of time with the guardians and those
tend to be moments when angela appears
most frequently in space with the
guardians we also know that valkyrie is
apparently swiping right for a new queen
of asgard
what would be first change
is kane is new king she needs to find
her queen
and angela is a prominent thor franchise
character you canonically can't rule out
for that matchmaking it's also one of
the last times that you can potentially
use her as thor's sister as old avengers
hand off their roles to the next
generation thor is kind of the only one
left cap is gone tony's gone natasha's
gone that leaves thor kind of alone i
guess hulk's there too but regardless it
feels like we're getting close to thor
having to make his move so if he's gonna
have a strong angelic warrior sister
reveal now's the time but most of all i
like how it works thematically thor has
nothing left his family is all dead his
homeland is exploded his friends are
spread across the universe to have a
sister a friendly non-murdery sister as
opposed to hella show up from another
universe and serve as an anchor for him
give him a way to reconnect and find
peace with his childhood yeah that'd be
pretty great and bringing it all the way
back around to the song that started it
all it fits a beautiful woman connected
to a lost childhood with bittersweet
undertones and a dark twist that prompts
the question where do we go now yeah
that is angela in a nutshell so there
you have it friends the two potential
twists of thor love and thunder thor's
mom is secretly the phoenix force or
thor's secret sister emerges from the
multiverse or you know sometimes a song
about a girlfriend is just a song about
a girlfriend and getting jane foster
back to down the suit is enough in what
looks to be an already packed movie
either way we're gonna find out in a few
months or who knows maybe even a few
days when the multiverse tears open in
doctor strange too strap in friends it
is 2022 and marvel is back in full force
it is going to be a big year because i
don't know if you forgot but black
panther 2 is also supposed to release in
november so we got a lot coming down the
pipe as always my friends remember it's
all just a theory a film theory and you
know they say that a healthy body is
made as much in the kitchen as it is in
gym or i suppose in thor's case giant
alien dungeon cave well if you're
working towards looking more like
pre-end game chris hemsworth rather than
post end game chris hemsworth this
summer have one recommendation for you
and that's our sponsor for today's
episode hellofresh hellofresh is a meal
kit service that offers you step-by-step
recipes that help you effortlessly save
both time and money with the food that
you're eating something i've always
found intimidating about cooking is the
work that it can require both in terms
of preparation and in cleanup but
hellofresh offers a ton of quick and
easy recipes that just melt the stress
away each of the recipes have super easy
to follow step-by-step instructions and
pre-portioned ingredients meaning that
i'm always winding up with the perfect
amount of food and not wasting a bunch
that goes bad in the refrigerator it's
also super easy to adjust our plans and
increase our order size on the occasions
that we have friends over and we want to
dazzle them with our amazing cooking
skills or you know we just want
leftovers the next day it's also cheaper
than going out and eating at a
restaurant up to 72 percent cheaper and
the food is just as good if not better
because hellofresh's recipes are
delicious they have 50 weekly options
that'll have you salivating they pull
recipes from all over the world want to
try something fancy well then treat
yourself to one of the top of the line
premium pick recipes every week or if
you're more in the mood for a side or a
dessert check out the hellofresh market
for all your snacking needs if you're
looking to eat healthier hellofresh can
help you reach your goals with their
range of veggie pescetarian and fit and
wholesome recipes so you can always feel
good about your food choices me
personally my goal is to look as good as
jane foster's biceps and help me in that
quest hellofresh can inject more protein
into my diet it has super flexible
options for adding swapping or upgrading
proteins each week including in their
veggie dishes speaking from personal
experience hellofresh's food is
delicious the instructions are super
easy to follow it saves me time in the
kitchen and honestly it makes me feel
like a halfway decent chef every time i
follow one of their recipes if any of
that piques your interest and you want
to try some amazing food for cheap go to
hellofresh.com and use the code film
theory16 to get up to 16 free meals and
three surprise gifts they say there's no
such thing as a free lunch but with
hello fresh right now you can get up to
16 free meals and three surprise gifts
again that is going down to the
description below and clicking the link
or going to hellofresh.com and using the
code film theory16
f-i-l-m-t-h-e-o-r-y-16 get yourself some
free food that's not gonna make you feel
guilty and honestly it's gonna make you
feel great for all the time that you
saved going to the grocery store check
it out right now hello fresh thank you
for being such a great sponsor of this
channel and for also being a great
sponsor of my diet cause man if it
wasn't for you i'd just be eating like
mcdonald's every single day of the week